With your RStudio Cloud account,
you'll have access to your own
personal workspace, as well as the ability
to create additional workspaces.
As an educator, you might find it
helpful to create
a single workspace
for each of your classes or workshops.
This creates a shared space
for all of the learners within a class,
allowing you to create
and share assignments with your learners,
as well as provide learners with a place
to complete their coursework.
What's more, you can view
the work of your learners
by going into their RStudio projects.
Once we log into RStudio Cloud,
navigate to the menu on the left
by clicking here.
We can also choose to keep this menu open
by clicking on this pin.
Here we see my personal workspace, as well
as a series of workspaces
that I've created or joined.
We can create a new workspace
by clicking on this new space button
and naming our new workspace.
For the purposes of this example,
I'll call our workspace Fall
2021 Data Visualization.
Once we're in the
workspace for a course,
we can create projects, add co-teachers
and teaching assistants, as well as add
learners and change access permissions .
These are all topics
covered in additional videos,
and I encourage you to check out
our RStudio Cloud playlist to learn more.